foreign
tool Google ads
what is Google ads
Google ads is a online platform or an
interface or a tool we can say or a
software which is developed by Google
to help the advertisers to run different
kind of ads on different publishing
sites or publishing platforms if I make
it more simple for you suppose you are
an Advertiser and you sell a digital
marketing course
so you know that the bulk of the traffic
would come from Google because this is
the most used search engine in the world
so when we type this we see a lot of
results here
and when we start a website it is very
difficult to rank organically or free or
through the SEO on the very first few
pages
with the help of Google ads in a very
starting days we can rank on the top
like
this this this
or this Advertiser so these are the four
top positions which right now has been
given to the advertisers who are playing
or who are running their ad using Google
ads
on a first page we see seven of such ads
four on the top I've shown you and three
on the bottom
so these are the maximum placements
which we see on a Google search page
this is the first kind of AD which can
be created under the Google ads tool
which we would definitely going to learn
today how to create such beautiful ad
copy second ad which generally we see on
different
sites like if I'll open any new site if
I'll open any block site if I open a
site like a speedtest.net then you would
see a beautiful banner or a responsive
ad like these these and these okay how
come I am able to say that these are ads
so if you'll just hover on this this
would say ads by Google
ads by Google so a different Advertiser
this is a Paramount this is from GoDaddy
and the publishing site which has been
selected by these advertisers is
speedtest.net
the Third Kind of AD which we generally
see on Google itself but in a different
colors and shape is called shopping ad
so if I just search suppose I want black
formal
shoes
then
the add copy is changed it is not
like a text ad which we have seen
earlier
though there is no text ad in this
search but we have just seen in the case
of digital marketing course
but it is an ad we can see from here
okay so this is called a shopping ad
then if I go and if I'll open
YouTube
and if I'll search a term maybe I am in
a search of email
for beginners course
and if I just play any of the videos a
random one
and before the video please
certainly we can skip after
five to six seconds and sometimes we see
a ad which streams but cannot be skipped
so these are video ads which again
created by this beautiful tool Google
ads one more ad Mobile Installation but
I cannot show you as I am from the
desktop though I would able to show you
the
screenshot of the same
now coming to the part why Google ad is
so important okay so I'll be just quick
now because we have to be making the
account today and also the campaign
Google ad is important in many ways
because Google ad helps us to increase
the visibility of our products increase
the visibility of our brand because you
can just imagine you were there
on Google but you were somewhere on
Sixth page or probably you know in the
next pagination if I just go and not
beyond that there are the results but
suppose you are you are on the sixth
page so we can just assume that nobody
goes beyond first or second I don't know
if you go or not but I don't go okay and
that's how the service is 97 of people
doesn't go beyond first to second page
so that means we have to be on a first
page if you really want to sell our
products so increasing that visibility
of our brand would take time if we just
keep waiting for SEO results to come or
to give us the first page or a second
page ranking so for that reason for a
quick results by making a relevant ad
copy and by targeting the right keywords
we can increase availability we can
increase the brand awareness we can
increase the traffic
okay we can also use a beautiful way of
retargeting or a remarketing where
people are able to recall our brand or
able to make the decisions if at a first
time they were not actually taken
suppose I say they went to my site
or any of the sites but in a very first
time they have not given me a result so
for me as this website the result is
getting the lead form field this is a
lead form and this is the page where we
have reached and where wherever you know
you would see a relevant page connected
to the particular ad that page is called
a landing page okay so this landing page
has a Content this landing page has an
objective to get the form field and this
landing page has a CTA which is called a
call to action okay so for me as an
Advertiser or as a digital marketer or
as a campaign manager of this brand BG
perform it's very important to get as
many as people to this page plus it is
the most important part that I get a lot
of form field and lot of CPA clicks or
this call to action clicks but every
time I cannot assume I have to be
realistic as well if even hundred or
thousand users have landed to my website
from the ad I cannot expect more than
three to five percent conversions okay
so if I say suppose 100 users have
reached my page today since morning so I
can only expect three to five percent of
leads or three to five users would have
filled the data but when we talk about a
remarketing then it is about retargeting
those guys who have reached here but did
not
filled up the data or did not convert it
or in the same case if I have taken them
to the black formal shoes site they
reached to the landing page or a product
page but did not bought the product so
for that reason we can always retarget
them using the website data so all these
things are very important once we start
learning Google ads deeply then you
would know how these works like you know
how the functionality of of these works
like okay so they are talking about the
same thing rlsa is retargeting list of
search ads we are able to Target people
who have not converted okay who have not
converted okay
then it is also used for
um I think I've talked about branding
now they're talking about how these
strategies work like so we generally
work on the different bid uh strategies
like how you pay to Google so the most
important one when it comes to Google
search ad this is called search art or
techstart is CPC so CPC is cost per
click okay now I'm talking about a very
important technical term the very first
technical term probably we have just
talked uh about the broadness off of the
Google ads how that is you know
important to increase The Branding
visibility and traffic we did talked
about the remarketing a bit but now I'm
getting into the campaign terms which is
going to be very important if you want
to learn today how to create a search
camp in a search art so the very first
thing is bidding strategy so we pay CPC
or it is also called PPC when we are
running this sort of an ad which is
called text ad this means cost per click
or pay per click so when somebody clicks
on this clicks on this clicks on this as
a user as a Searcher as a viewer then
only a Advertiser would pay to Google
this is what PPC means pay per click
marketing so Advertiser is getting
advantage that till the time the ad has
only been shown
he is not paying any Penny to Google but
the movement a very first user comes and
clicks on it then the amount of certain
bid value starts deducting from the
advertisers Google ads account which we
certainly going to be creating for you
guys as well in a while okay so you
create a Google ads account you put some
money into it you start running the ad
of different sort text ad Banner ad
video ad shopping ad and the movement
somebody clicks or somebody watches a
video or somebody takes any action on
your ads then only you pay most of the
times okay that is what the CPC strategy
works like
then also it is a very important part
that we should know how we are measuring
the results so in anywhere in the
digital marketing if you talk from my
experience I know we are only able to
get better results or we are only able
to get more conversions if we are just
not running the ad we have to be first
researching how the ads should be
created we have to be working on the
areas which should not be filled uh we
should not be left unfilled and it
should be focused on the audience it
should be focused on certain
parameters and after running the ad also
it is very important to keep measuring
the performance and optimizing
optimizing and optimizing further or
otherwise taking care in the next
campaign okay so I think superficially
we have talked about lot of things on a
go why not just to get into the Google
ads now see how the account is created
for free and then let's make a campaign
first and we'll come back and we
understand we'll try to understand some
of the important things like you know
there are metrics which we have to be
seeing there are formats okay so formats
I've already talked about okay so this
is the text that I've already shown then
there is a banner ad which I've shown
you on the uh you know speedtest.net
there is another kind of an ad image
that again you know you see on a
different platforms like websites and
apps then there is a app ad which I
could not show you practically because I
am logged in from my desktop so this was
the fifth kind of an ad which I was
talking about a Mobile Installation ad
so this probably you see only on most of
the time on a mobile because as an
Advertiser he would want that
installation Button as a CTA should be
directly placed under the ad so that if
person searches for something on a
mobile then the ad is directly showing
them the installation button and the app
can be downloaded into their mobile
gadgets okay so now then there is a
video ad which we already seen in the
shopping ad I've already shown you okay
then there's a another ad which is just
a call only though it is again you know
created by the Google ads only we will
see
now coming to create the Google ads okay
so first of all
creating the campaign we need to be
having a Google ads account that's a
very first requirement so I'll just help
you now how you create a Google ads
account for free by using your Gmail ID
okay so we go to Google
let me just search probably here itself
and we type Google ads just ensure that
you are logged in with any of your Gmail
ID
and then we see Google ads
on a top
then we just need to click this
and
once you reach to this page you have to
click get started
after get started probably in my case
you would see a different screen because
I have lot of accounts created a lot of
clients accounts are there but in your
case it will show new Google Earth
account
like this
so I will repeat my steps so that you're
not confused
so you go on Google
you type Google ads
you click Google ads the very first
result
or either if it is not showing in your
country in your location then you have
to just find ads.google.com
and you click get started
okay the moment you click get started
you would directly reach to this page
okay that's why I just repeated my steps
because I have been taken to some other
page where my already created accounts
were showing but in your case after just
clicking get started it will directly
going to take you to this page now here
you have to ensure that you are not
clicking anything why because this has
brought us to the express mode Express
mode is more of the kind like automated
or a smart mode which is created by
Google for uh making the quick ads you
know it is not going to be showing you
all the exhaustive settings or you know
advanced settings inside so for that
reason what we do we go down we just you
know I've just I've just scroll down
okay and then switch to expert mode
okay I'll again repeat when we click
this get started we reach to this page
where it takes us to the smart or
Express mode where we don't have to be
doing anything we scroll down and we
click on a switch to export mode
once we click that
then you would see few things which you
have just seen in the PPD probably that
what is your objective why you have come
here we have come here to increase your
sales leads website traffic and XYZ
things but because right now I'm just
teaching you are just letting you know
how the account is created then we can
ignore these tabs for a moment of course
in a while we'll talk about these as
well so we'll just scroll down and we'll
create a account without a campaign as I
said we are going in a sequence so we
are not creating the campaign first I am
considering most of the users would not
have the Google ad account as of now so
I am going that way so you create the
account first without a campaign so when
you click this
then you see
there are a few basic questions been
asked like from which country you are
billing would be which time zone you
want to follow or which currency you
would be paying in okay once this is
done just click submit
okay just click submit
once this is done congrats you're all
done okay then you just need to click on
explore your account
and this takes you to the
dashboard of this beautiful tool Google
ads from where we can start our journey
of making the very first Gap
okay so now let's again come back to the
PPT because our account is created now
before making the campaign what all
things should be cleared let's discuss
okay so you can create all these kind of
campaigns or with all these goals inside
the Google ads which we have just
learned how to be creating the account
okay how the account is created we can
create the campaign to increase the
sales we can in we can increase the
leads by running the ads you can
increase our website traffic we can work
for the product branding or a
consideration we can also work for brand
awareness and app promotion okay these
are the subdefined goals or predefined
goals before we jump into the campaign
making of a search or display or a video
okay I I hope this all these all are
very much defined or self-defined one so
I don't have to be you know telling you
what is sales and what is branding and
what is awareness but still if you feel
so in a while I will just going to throw
some light on it okay then
setting up the ad group so I'll be just
making all this practically with you so
we don't again you know have to be
understanding all this now coming to
some of the metrics which you would see
inside
the campaign once that is created so
let's just go back and
see one of the
ads from any of my clients so that we
can learn better
only I'll just open in a different tab
okay
so if I just have to show you
probably I can just use right now the
demo account of assembly line where
important metrics
we can discuss which which has already
been given in the PPT but of course I
would just show you how they look like
inside the campaigns or inside the
Google ads account so if we move to the
dashboard when we have created and if we
have already been running any campaigns
and we want to see results or any of the
metrics then what we do we go into all
campaigns
and from here we can see all sort of
campaigns created in the past okay
because I want to see only the results
from the search campaigns because there
are all kind of campaigns been created
here like video campaigns and display
and all so what I can do I can click
this
this law of uh navigation menu on the
top left
and then I can just select the search
campaigns
when this is selected
only these search campaigns would be
visible
now if I just go on any of the campaign
suppose inside
then this breadcrumbs changes earlier I
was only in the all campaigns then I
just selected search campaigns and now
inside the search campaigns I have
selected a specific campaign okay so
considering suppose this was the
campaign I have run in the January for
any of my digital marketing sales okay
or any of my product sales or any of my
services lead generation XYZ objectives
could have been okay now coming to the
main part
from The Matrix point of view so we see
here that there are
results been shown of course because
this is a demo account so you don't see
numbers we can always change the dates
like suppose I want to see the uh result
of last 30 days so I would just go here
and this would show these many
Impressions have come Impressions like
how many times the ad is just been seen
okay impression means just how many
times the ad been seen okay then it
would show how many times the ad
actually been clicked okay how many
times had been clicked assuming 100
times The Impressions have come and two
clicks have come so the percentage which
is basically a ratio of a clicks to
impression is called CTR
a click-through rate which is the next
one
clicks impression and CTR okay so
click-through rate is the ratio of
impression to clicks your ad been shown
hundred of times or 100 times probably
but only click today for three times so
your CTR is three percent your ad been
shown
100 times but been clicked seven times
so your CTR is seven percent which is a
very good number okay anything around 5
to 10 is good okay we don't get to see
lot of Clicks in our initial days
because people do trust the brands which
are already established but slowly
gradually with the right branding with
the right awareness our click rate
increases our CTR increases okay then
comes your average CPC which certainly
you would see here as well so average
CPC is a price which you actually end up
in paying for every click
okay so there is a bid value bid value
means when you started to create your
account or with a campaign of a search
then you decide for certain keywords
that how much money you would pay for
every click okay that is called a bid
price which we certainly see here okay
and once you start getting the clicks
after running your campaign then the
exact pricing been shown as a average
CPC price okay then comes the cost cost
is basically going to be your
multiplication of number of clicks
you've got with the average CPC you have
paid suppose you have got 100 clicks
today and for every click you paid five
rupees
so 100 into 5 going to be 500 or if you
uh understand by the dollars so suppose
for every click you have paid one USD so
for 100 clicks you pay 100 USD by the
end of a day okay that is going to be
your day cost or average cost you have
paid for
particular ad on a particular day that
is also understood by saying daily
budget you have spent okay so if I have
allotted that I would pay 900 rupees a
day and 9 900 rupees a day in the
average of the CPC if I would have
probably 10 Rupees so I will get 90
clicks okay because 90 clicks into 10
Rupees for a click I'm going to exhaust
my 900 per day budget if this would have
been 100 dollars
and then 100 clicks multiplied by one
dollar will going to exhaust my hundred
dollars per day okay this is how Google
calculates like for how much uh budget
you want to run the ad for and on
various factors your average cost per
click is decided okay this is the uh
understanding of all these terms cost
per conversion and conversion depends
that how your next step actually been
designed so by Next Step I mean suppose
if I talk about this particular ad only
a person clicks and person reaches here
okay so we can Define the conversions
like suppose 100 people have reached
here on the landing page this means 100
clicks would have happened okay so the
dashboard would say
thousand Impressions 100 clicks one
rupee 100 rupee okay one rupee being the
average CPC 100 clicks we have received
and we have spent 100 rupees but it
doesn't mean that all those 100 clicks
which actually
took the users to the landing page would
have been converted okay so when the
conversion code has been placed on the
confirmation page which opens after the
conversion happens or after the goal
completes so that actually tells us how
many people got converted or how many
people actually uh fulfilled or
completed our objective of goal whatever
it was regeneration sales uh download
brochure any of the subscriptions any of
the ctOS we talk about okay
so uh talking about the numbers suppose
only three people or two people or two
users have filled this data okay so the
numbers in my dashboard would be like
1000 Impressions have been shown 100
clicks have come means 100 people have
reached to the landing page but only two
conversions have happened okay and the
cost for all the clicks would be like
100 rupees because average CPC was one
rupee okay so when the conversion is 2
then we can say that our conversion rate
was two percent why because out of 100
clicks I was only able to get two people
across the confirmation page or across
that CTA which was a call to action of
buy now shop now or sign up or download
whatever it was that is called a
convergence and conversion rate two
percent cost per conversion can only
also be divided like two conversions
I've got in 100 rupees so my cost per
conversion would be 50 rupees okay my
average CPC is one my clicks been
hundred my Impressions been thousand my
CTA been ten percent how 100 divided by
thousand CTR 10 percent I have a cpc1
cost becomes 100 rupees my conversions
been to that's why my conversion rate is
two percent and my cost per conversion
comes like 50 why because I've got two
conversions on the spent of 100 that
brings 50 rupees here
I hope this is clear if I have to just
demonstrate
you just wait
so that this is basically you know
uh been captured in your heads with more
clarity so I'm just going to
use a normal example
impressions
the same numbers which I just explained
so that you know
okay so this is cost per conversion
suppose your ad received thousand
impressions today 100 clicks have come
so your CTR becomes ten percent because
that is how this is calculated clicks by
Impressions wherever CPC was one rupee
or it has
a billion dollars so your cost would be
100 rupees
100 dollars
you've got two conversions means two
people or two users have uh bought
anything or have subscribed or have just
you know completed that call to action
and the conversion rate for that reason
would be 2 divided by hundred so two
percent
and cost per conversion in this case
would be 50 rupees because you have paid
100 rupees for two conversions and in
this case it would be fifty dollars just
a hypothetical number did not be very
much worried about the numbers okay with
the high priest okay this would change
certainly when we do the research of our
keywords
okay
now coming
to the part how now these ads been
created that's the most important part
how we create a beautiful ad copies and
all that okay so we go
into the campaign making by all campaign
and then we click on a campaign
we will click on a new campaign
Google ads most of the time works low
nowadays so you have to be a bit patient
with this and then we click on a create
campaign without a goal guidance or we
can always click website traffic lead
sales okay these all four can be created
uh for the Google ad search campaign you
know we can only use these four for the
search app because if I'll just click
this this will not allow me to create
search ad this only allows video ad if
I'll click this this only allows display
and video ad this only allows mobile ad
and this is for the local so if I have
to create a search ad like this or a
text ad like this so I have to be either
creating through sales leads or website
or either without a guidance so I'll
just going to be teaching you all the
settings inside so that you know the
Google ads uh you know search ad
settings in advanced level so I'm just
taking without a tool then you click
search ads
our focus is just to create search ad
you can leave this part right now
because your conversions are not being
created we'll do in maybe in the next
session when we'll talk about the
advanced settings and website visit is
my Premiere goal and suppose I am
running the ad for any of these sites
probably I'm running the ad for
you just see if I can get the simply
learn landing page
so this remarkable search
marketing
just terminate ways
yeah digital marketing
course
click on continue
and then the very first thing you see
bidding which we have just learned that
we pay on the cost per click basis so
clicks
and you can always set up your
bid limit that I do not want to pay more
than suppose one rupee I click or two
rupiah click or five rupee attack
okay and there is another
thing which you have to be discussing
before we talk about the bid limit so
let me just take you to the
Keyword Planner so this comes from here
tool settings
Keyword Planner
so that we get an overview that how much
actually we should be paying for every
keyword we are running the ad for
suppose my keyword for which I want to
run the ad is digital marketing code
that is the Premier keyword or the most
searched keyword by which
the ads of a competitors also are
showing and also I want to show my ad
for okay so what I would do I would just
go into this beautiful tool I again
repeat my steps I can just go tool in
settings
Keyword Planner open in a right tab why
so that your existing campaign settings
are not Disturbed okay you come here you
click this and you click discover new
keywords and you search your term like
digital marketing course
click get results
and then you are able to see
digital marketing course in the period
of last one year in India of course you
can change the country to U.S Canada
Australia anywhere and you would see in
the last one year how many search
queries on a monthly basis have come for
this particular keyword in addition you
see lot of suggestions as well suppose
we'll just sticking around one keyword
right now to understand the bid part and
all so we see that we got around 1
million searches in India for this
particular keyword with the competition
of medium competition medium means that
most of the advertisers who are selling
this digital marketing course been
running the ad for the This this term or
not if this competition would have been
high then I should have ignored this or
would have changed the keyword but this
is medium so I would take this and this
you know talks about the bid value this
is the low term and this is the high
term like low price means this is the
lowest price any of the advertisers
would have paid this year for this
particular term to show the ad and this
is the highest bid price which any of
the advertisers would have paid in this
year for this term so they doesn't tell
which part of year it was which
Advertiser it was but at least we get a
fair idea that our bid value would be
around 46 to 195. so we go bit smart
we go on the average price suppose a bit
46 so I'll just go 30 40 percent over
this price so suppose I take 30 percent
around 12 rupees or 13 rupees so that
makes it 15 and around 60 rupees so this
is the bid value I am aiming 60 rupees
plus what I do I take some of the
keywords which I feel like from a naked
eye at this moment are very important
for my campaign just like I take this I
take this I take this
now you can just take any of them
you can download this data into Excel
and copy paste as well so there are a
lot of ways to do this
okay and then you can certainly
just name the new ad group and they
would be added to it or otherwise it is
very easy
that we just copy them from here okay
there are ways to do it so this is the
simplest of the way suppose I just liked
all these keywords from my product point
of view and I like the pricing as well
so what I would do I would just copy
this
copying this
and then putting into maybe here
so when there would be a space you know
when the campaign would ask me please
tell me for which keyword you want to
run the ad
certainly it would come here when we are
done with these two settings then I
don't have to waste time I will just go
here and copy these
keyword and paste in here under the
keywords okay I can take more but before
you know the time exhaust because I have
a uh you know in my head that I have to
complete all the campaign settings and
everything within one hour so that
you're not bored of this and I want that
energy level to be on a higher side so
you can do this research probably and
you can also you know add a lot of
keywords you know dependent on how much
you know you wanna actually leverage
from them and as well more keywords
means you end up in paying your budget
uh you know in a very quick basis so
it's important that we segregate them
from the monthly searches High monthly
searches keywords are always important
because the demand is high and then we
always check the competition should not
be higher okay so I probably would not
take these you know because these are
high ones okay I can delete and I can
always aim the low ones like medium
medium medium and medium so I can just
take this okay so copy and we'll be
replacing these
because I got the better keywords now as
compared to the other ones because they
had the high competition keywords as
well so I'm just now aiming the medium
keywords with the higher searches and I
have just decided that I would give the
bid value or a highest bid cap of a 60
rupees because I have just seen the
average that if I have to rank for this
particular one or probably this one or
probably this one you know which are on
the higher side then I should be paying
40 50 extra as you know compared to the
low priced okay so that is how the bid
value is calculated roughly okay anyhow
you would only pay to uh you know
outrank your competitor that's how the
algorithm works like you will not going
to pay high amount it is like if three
advertisers are bidding on a certain
term then if the next one to you is
paying 2 rupee or two dollars so just to
outrank him you would end up in paying
some amount over it like 2.1 or 2.2 it
is not like that you would be paying 40
rupees so that's how the algorithm
calculates okay you you put anything as
an account as a bid value but it will
only going to take I have a CPC
depending on how the competitors are
working and how their pricing is being
given okay so just on a safer side we
give our average price but moreover to
save the cost of the CPC we work on the
quality score or on the quality of our
content and on the ad which certainly is
a very important part okay so coming
back to the campaign making we come here
and we give a bit value suppose of 50
because this is what we have seen or
other 60 from that particular you know
keyword sheet from here 30 40 percent
over this particular keyword which is
the most important one for me and then I
click next
once this is done then I just select my
Google search Network I don't have to
select the Display Network because this
will going to put my text ad on the
different websites and apps Display
Network are good when we are running the
banner ad because we are just running
the search ad so we're just going to
keep it around the Google search result
and Google sites like Google News Google
Maps Google shop Google YouTube so all
the text ad wherever the placements can
be given so it will going to take
directly we don't put on our search
Partners too because that is again going
to lose the visibility search patterns
are like ask.com AOL newarktimes.com
okay so again you know it is my strategy
that I don't want to increase the
visibility outside Google I'm very happy
in showing my most of the Impressions
around Google only okay or either on a
Google widgets like these wherever the
text ad has a possibility just like you
might be wondering how come I said
YouTube so if I just go here and if I
just type again this so probably you
would see text ads on the top okay
nowadays there are a lot of Tech stats
been running so this is a tech start
okay this is not a video this is not a
banner ad this is the banner ad this is
the text ad okay so this is coming from
here only
Google sites okay then comes your
location you can run the ad on different
locations by you know sitting anywhere
suppose I'm gonna run that for the
worldwide then I'll select all countries
and territories if I want to select
particular country like India or I want
to select multiple countries like
suppose United States
foreign
or I want to select
Canada
or I want to select India too
so I can do this way
Okay then if I want to exclude any of
these states probably suppose I wanna
exclude Texas from here so I'll click
Texas and I'll click exclude
I wanna
exclude probably
uh Mumbai
so Mumbai as a city can be excluded
and probably I wanna exclude Ontario
from Canada
because of XYZ reasons just to explain
the settings I'm doing this so this is
also done
okay then we also can use advanced
search where a beautiful setting of
radius can be worked and the second
advantage of advances tab is that you
are able to see the map so whatever you
have selected like we have selected
Canada and us and whatever you have
deselected or excluded will come in red
blue part included red part X2 did the
same way you would see in India as well
blue part included and this small dot
Mumbai excluded okay plus we can do the
radius targeting here suppose I sell
something within the radius of one or
two kilometers or one or two miles so I
have to just select that part suppose if
I just deselect India right now
and deselect the Mumbai exclusion as
well and consider that I have a
restaurant or a cake shop in Delhi
and probably I will also add this
keyword into my keywords so that that
matches the term if anybody searches
this I have to be seeing the character
limits that's why you have to be always
checking and changing things accordingly
okay then digital marketing Google
then simply learn till
marketing
digital
marketing
online course probably if we can get
that space
okay
then going down and we can always see
where we are lacking right now so we
have not very good headlines been added
including popular keywords been there
description works well so let's see what
they give us the idea like
so they say
we are not given any online availability
brand call to actions okay I'm just
going to play with some of the terms now
so let's just see
from CTA using the ctnr
you can see the strength has improved
learn
I don't know it is actually
pausing my recording again and again and
that could be disturbance for you guys
so I'm just taking some time so that
this comes back to normal
okay so this is how you can add up to
headlines 10 headlines and that would
improve your ad strength and last not
least you can add the descriptions which
are very relevant to the ad copy okay
try to get some headlines or
descriptions here from the landing page
okay once this is done you can just
click done here
and your ad copy is prepared you can see
here very much and click next
and then you can set up your budget so
the budget which we were talking earlier
in the Excel if I have to show you so
you got 100 clicks you have paid one
rupee for every click so you have given
100 rupees per day so this is your daily
budget which you have spent okay so you
can always decide your daily budget by
setting or customizing it you can put
anything though it is showing dollars
but this is INR you can see here this is
kind of a bug which we are seeing since
almost a month now so your average daily
cost which they say like a weekly cost
rather after 41 multiplying by 33 for
every CPC price would come to 1382 but
we are giving a daily price so we can
always divide this by seven or you know
by 10 probably so I'm just giving a
rough number 100 okay or thousand could
have been you know 500 also it was being
given okay
so every day I would spend 500 and
accordingly my clicks you know would
come and then you click next
and your ad goes to review like they
would going to be checking your landing
page they will be checking your uh you
know uh what else the ad copy everything
can be checked and would take some time
I think I just need to change that
let me just keep it
5 am
so this is simpler
and then just click next
and publish the campaign from here
publish
so once this is done
then your ad which can be checked from
here
would go into a review part and it would
say
under review once this is approved then
your ad start showing and you start
seeing the results like impression
clicks and CTR obviously busy whatever
we have talked about
okay so this is all about the hard
making now we can see some of the
important things there like Matrix we
have discussed
all these we have discussed CPC
conversions cost per conversions
CTR the only thing which you have
noticed is the quality score so quality
score is you know completely
um the part at the backend which works
like to improve our ranking so quality
score is something which has been given
out of 10 and when we see our ad which
is already been created like suppose for
this campaign if I'll take you so if I
just go to the keywords
so every keyword been given quality
score out of 10.
okay so if any of the keyword has got 10
out of 10 it means there are three
important elements like their CTR like
how many clicks have come their landing
page and their ad copy is relevant or
not okay they see three elements how
relevant the landing pages how relevant
is the ad copies and certainly they see
how relevant being the add copy with the
search then only your CTR increases
somebody searches something in the art
shows and if the clicks are high then
the CTR goes high so that's why the CTR
the landing page and the add relevance
has to be above average that's how you
know they Define they don't give Marks
here they give total marks out of 10
here the quality score so above average
is going to be the highest average going
to be the middle one and the below
average is going to be the lowest one
okay so if you have any issues uh in any
of these elements then your overall
quality score impacts okay this is all
the quality score so high quality score
means you end up in paying less and you
get a better value for your money okay
that's I think the last part of it so
Google ad ratings of quality of your ads
keyword and landing pages I think this
is what I've been given here as well
then you check I have already shown you
you check the keyword you tell the
timing which which was the best timing
you have from the ad which was the best
locations your ad has actually called
the result from and then accordingly
your ad can be optimized and can be
changed you change your budget you
change your bid price you change your
location you change your timing you
change your headline it all depends
after your ad actually been shown and
then you research or you do the analysis
like you know we are seeing which
keyword is working better which keyword
is having the best of the cost which
keyword is giving you the good
impression to interaction rate like a
CTR then we check the ad copy copy you
know how the ad is working suppose if I
have multiple ads to just compare if
this ad works better or this ad works
better this ad works better so I would
just going to
be comparing these three ads which one
has given me the better of the clicks as
compared to the other one which has
given me the better CTR whose CPC was
lesser who CPC was higher that is how I
will be checking it okay I can always
have number of ads created under the
campaign just like are we right now we
have created one campaign one ad we can
always test with the another ad copy by
clicking this so that we can see which
ads performs better okay that's why in
this existing account you can see
multiple ads so because we were testing
which one works better so this is how
you can also make one other AD copy and
you can just click done and that would
be added to the list of ads okay you can
see now one more ad actually been added
so out of these two which one works
better would be only uh diagnosed or
checked if the ad starts running okay
you can always add your account the you
know money the the billing part into the
student settings building summary
and from here you just need to add your
mode of payment okay you have to select
your country you have to select the
currency you know you are paying in and
then of course you would have options to
pay like debate money transfer net
banking and India paytm wallet is also
available very much available
we are on Google and when we type
something like if I want to do a data
analytics course
so I would type few things like a word
or a keyword or a query into Google
search engine and then Google has a
search engine would show me few results
the results which we see on the top we
are talking about these today you know
this is the topic or this is the kind of
an ad which we would create today in
this session this is called Tech start
or this is also called Google search ad
okay so this is the first type of an ad
you see or which you can create under
the Google ads there are few more just
like if you would go and search for any
of the e-commerce product probably by
winter
jacket
online
so then there would be results but in a
different shape and color and different
structure there is an ad which is a text
ad but on the top we are able to see
some more ads but they are not just text
they have a pricing they have a title
they have a brand name they have an
image of the product so they are called
shopping ads or product listing ads in
addition to that sometimes you know when
you go to a product a website like speed
test and you see the product ads there
but again in the different shape and
color so they are called
display ads because they've been
displayed on different websites and
different apps so why I'm going so fast
in explaining you different type of ads
because as I told you we have another
video created uh with the name of Google
ads for beginners 2023 you can just
check the link in the description and
you will able to get all this type of
ads and whatever the uh you know bidding
strategies to be used in basic in that
particular tutorial or that demo just
has to show you if you can see that ads
by Google so this is the display Adder
Banner right just quickly I have shown
you three types of the ads but our Focus
as I said today going to be on a very
specific ad which
is the most important ad from the Google
ads family okay so let's just begin guys
when I come to Google ads this is how
the Google ad structure looks like
we have a Google ads account created
again I repeat if you don't know how to
create it please find the link in the
description to create the Google ads
account once a Google ads account
created then you would have a dashboard
like this okay in this dashboard you can
see there are campaigns there are ad
groups there are ads there are videos
there are landing pages so a lot of
things can be confusing if we are just
coming to this account or to this
beautiful tool for the very first time
so to just keep it very simple or to
explain in uh in a very simpler way what
I did is I just drawn this structure for
you okay so the structure says that you
have a Google ads account imagine that I
am a simply learned Google ads manager
so I am running the ads for all simply
learn keywords like data analytics
course digital marketing course or any
machine learning course python course so
whenever somebody types this so there is
a ad which shows like from Simply learn
probably we have to just assume because
currently I'm not able to see any simple
an ad here so data analytics course
India
and then probably we can see if there
are any
you can always change the keywords but
just to test time randomly changing the
words
or I could have just written simply
learn specifically because I want to go
with simple learn only I have researched
a lot and I feel like this is one of the
best okay so probably there is no ad
though
still I would check
probably I have to just change the
chords
so I will go for the another course
which is by simply learn again and then
probably we can expect any of the ads
running
because this is not a very peak time so
we are probably you know saving some of
the cost not running the ads at this all
hour anyhow so we can assume that this
is the ad you know I am running for so
how we can create this ad how we can get
the best of clicks as I said it is not
the very best time to run the ad so this
is also kind of a change you know we can
bring into our ads by doing some
research so how all these things are
done we're going to be learning it okay
so when we come here to the dashboard
and then we see our dashboard looks like
this a bit complicated so we can be
confused we can be disheartened that I
have created the account by seeing uh
the first video but now I am all stucked
okay so probably I have to again wait so
the wait is over now we are here to
understand the whole structure okay so
let me just take a very simple example
suppose I uh I'm someone who's selling a
shoes okay because I have just said
simply learned probably let's just
convert it to any of the Google ads
account of a shoe seller probably I am
Nike okay and I am making the we had for
Nike shoes and I am selling two types of
the Nike shoes today probably formal or
Canvas OR probably I am selling the
casual or any sport shoes and what I did
I created the campaign named it search
ad
uh any month you know whatever the month
you have started with suppose November
so November 2022 that is the name which
I am giving name can be changed name is
something which is being put it up for
my reference so that after creating a
lot of campaigns I'm not confused in
which campaign I have to check the
results okay so I'm running the server
chart for shoes for the month of
February or November or December 22 23
whatever and then I open two ad groups
into it why I'm opening two ad groups
under one campaign because I'm selling
two kind of products under the shoes
only I am selling formal also
under the shoes only I am selling casual
also so what happens suppose I would
have just you know created one art group
and would have inserted or submitted all
the keywords of formal and Casual inside
one hat group then if somebody would
have searched a term called formal black
shoes then this ad group would have got
confused that should I show formal ad
shoes or should I show casual art shoes
because what I did I have just got all
my keywords like formal casual Cricket
shopping jogging party office you know
all the mix of the keywords from formal
and Casual family into the same ad group
The Movement any of these six keywords
being typed or been searched on Google
then this ad group would have got
triggered and then again randomly it
would have shown the ad of a formal or
ad of a casual because both of the ads
would have been under this okay but
after doing this bifurcation or after
doing this segmentation what would
happen all the formal keywords like
party shoes office shoes formal shoes
formal black shoes would go here
this ad group would trigger if any of
this keyword would search and
accordingly this ad which has everything
related to only formal shoes will be
shown and of course with that ad the
landing page is connected which would be
open you know when somebody clicks the
ad okay and vice versa if somebody would
have searched for a casual term like a
casual shoes sports shoes jogging shoes
running shoes then this ad group would
have triggered and then the casual shoes
ad with all the headline related to that
casual keywords would have been shown
and accordingly if somebody would have
clicked then the landing page of casual
shoes you know would have opened okay so
if this is clear actually you are very
much ready to uh dive into the Google
ads because many people takes a lot of
time to understand the structure because
uh you know maybe they are very much
confused at the art group level but I
have just tried My Level based by
bringing this example why I am creating
two different ad groups I why I'm not
just going with the same ad group you
know mixing all the keywords
second scenario could have been on a
second permutation could have been I
would have just you know probably
created two different campaigns all
together I would have named The Campaign
one with search ad formal shoes November
okay then only that only this part would
have belonged to the first campaign then
I would have created a different
campaign all together and would have
named it campaign search ad
casual shoes November then this second
campaign or a second campaign can be
assumed here with you know with a green
color would have been drawn okay so this
is how on the structure it works like we
can always now create inside so let's
just see a few things uh before we
create the ad okay very important uh
requirement or rather I would say uh if
being the campaign manager of any any
any any company you name any startup you
name or any client you work with or
probably for yourself as well you have
to be very much sure how these terms
works like Okay so this terms when I
talk about is going to be bit inclined
towards the search ad today only and
when I talk about the display ad in the
next video then I would you know take
you through about the terminologies and
all the kpis off display Banner or video
ads okay so now if I talk about a search
ad a very important
um term which we should be aware of is
the maximum bid price
okay because we all know when we're
talking about this ad which is called a
text ad then we are paying on every
click okay that's why this is also
called PPC ad this is also called PPC
marketing or you can understand in a
very simple words uh Advertiser which is
Emirates this in this particular ad only
has to pay when somebody like Sachin
this movement clicking this ad I click
this ad I reach to the landing page of
this particular University or this
college and a certain amount is deducted
from this particular ad account and and
that certain amount actually decides or
decided on the basis of the keyword
helped to show this ad okay so as an
Advertiser must have paid something to
Google ads for showing this ad for this
keyword okay so when I say a maximum bit
price it means it's a maximum bid price
of a keyword that's why now this would
be easier to understand by this example
suppose I want to run the ad on the term
called data analytics course 2022 what I
did I have opened the Google Keyword
Planner you know I did talked about this
in the previous session but I will take
you through again how you use a Keyword
Planner smartly so I have got this data
from the keywords planner that the
average price I have to pay for this
keyword to show my ad is 5 to 10 Rupees
so what I did I just played a bit of
maths and I have bidded something over
the minimum bit price okay this is the
minimum bit price is the maximum bit
price okay and this is what I've got
from the Keyword Planner so rather than
going for a very high price or the
maximum bit price to secure my position
I want to play safe and what I would do
I would just take a chance maybe 30 40
over the minimum bit range and then I
will see if the Impressions or clicks
are coming or not if this starts coming
it means that my ad is accepted and my
keyword is you know winning in the
auction and I'm able to get the clicks
but if it is not picking then certainly
I have to increase my bid price but
coming back to the terminology is what
we're talking here is once I have set it
up my maximum bit price of 7 rupees then
my ad would start showing suppose my ad
shows for thousand times today and every
time when my ad been clicked you know
certain amount being deducted there is a
competition there are other advertisers
also you know who are running the ad and
after showing my ad for the whole day
Google in the dashboard just shown that
you have paid average CPC of 5 rupees
only so I bid it for 7 but by seeing
different uh you know factors like the
competition the demand and how many
times the ads got clicked what was the
position where my ad was shown I ended
up in paying five rupees for every Click
by the end of a day so the average CPC
sometimes you know people get confused
they have a CPC and the maximum bit
price the same no so maximum bit price
is something which I uh you know submit
to Google that this is the maximum I can
pay for my ad to show on certain keyword
for every click and I have a CPC
something which actually you know I pay
every day or you know in that average of
the duration you had got displayed or
got clicks uh for every uh click on that
particular keyword okay or the number of
keywords if you have more than one
keyword submitted and suppose I've got
100 clicks then you know it's a simple
math that my budget which I have spent
today is five rupees for one click 500
rupees 400 click so daily budget would
be 500 rupees and tomorrow if company
says I need 300 clicks then of course my
average CPC which I have from the
historical date of yesterday you know I
would just do my maths and I will going
to submit the daily budget of not 100
rather 300 today so that in 1500 I can
expect 300 clicks at the cost of five
rupees per click okay so this is a very
simple of the example to just make you
explain how things works you know you
submit something then on the basis of a
lot of factors you know Google
calculates Google gives you clicks and
once you have the data then you know you
can just understand how this all is
working okay last thing before we dive
into the tool is Keyword Planner so I
just told you we have done in the last
class how this works like so we go into
tool and setting and then we go into
Keyword Planner I'll show you in the
account also the Google ads account just
after 30 seconds uh the screenshot's
over so your Keyword Planner opens and
then you discover the keyword suppose I
am selling data analytics course so I
would just put my search term data
analytics course and then I'll click the
get result and then accordingly it will
show me lot of options and this is the
pricing I was talking about it gives me
the low price and the high price so I
would take the 30 40 percent over the
low bid price or the average price
between these both and that would be my
maximum bit price and after checking all
the permutations Google would show my ad
or either it would not show my ad also
there can be a chance so I have to just
wait for my impression and clicks and
the results by the end of a day and I
would you know I would know uh how much
the average CPC actually I'm paying for
each keyword okay so I'll show you all
those reports in a while uh that's it
right now let's just go and see few
things so the Keyword Planner will start
with suppose I start
you know in researching all these things
my campaign is about data analytics
course
I'm making it for Centurion probably and
I would go and I would just try to you
know search into planning my Keyword
Planner and then I will write a term
quickly here you know whatever I want to
show my ad for
suppose data analytics course as I said
okay let's check digital marketing
because we would have more
results so it's
easy to understand with a lot of results
because I would be able to tell you how
to sort and filter them down uh digital
marketing course and you can just test
it with any of the keywords I'm just
doing a random check
so once we are here we have a lot of
keywords in addition to what we have
submitted so the keyword which I have
provided is this and the result shows
that it had over 100k uh you know
monthly searches and uh of course in the
range of 1 million in the in the in in
the month of 2021 to September 22 so
this is actually the average monthly
searches happened in between this period
and uh the advertise is actually paid as
low as 44 Rupees to as high 20 224
rupees okay that can easily be uh you
know converted to dollars uh half a
dollar or maybe more than half a dollar
UH 60 70 cents probably and this is like
going to be a three dollars cost okay so
what we can do is we can see now there
are a lot of keywords been given and we
can easily sort them down here on
certain you know bases like you know
suppose the monthly searches are high or
the bid is low and all that stuff but
this is quite you know difficult when we
have to sort down here in the Keyword
Planner so what I do is I'm just going
to talk about the same you know like hi
how I actually go when I am working for
my clients okay I have clients here a
lot of clients I don't want to show you
but yeah I have and um suppose I just go
and download this data from here
and then this would be you know
downloaded in the Excel format and we
can just save it anywhere suppose I just
bring it here and then now I would open
the keyword sheet
I would have a data in my Excel okay so
I need this this one so this is the most
important column because I have to
highlight uh which column is important
and what is not required right now so
whatever is required I'm just I'll be
keeping with me and what I feel like is
not very important as of now I'm just
not going to be taking them so now there
are
five column which I have kept with
myself like
4 where we talk about the results
and the keyword okay this is not
required this is not required so I'm
just going to be deleting or hiding them
okay so when we talk about our
competition index value so this actually
tells us that a particular keyword is
how much uh you know from the
competition point of view is difficult
to rank suppose I talk about two
keywords right now let me just take
um a one with a lower score suppose this
one and I would take the higher or the
highest one probably is this one okay so
now when I talk about a comparison you
know probably uh or or probably let's
say this this one because this has a
monthly searches which are equivalent uh
you know from the compression point of
view they are very different but the
search has been same so if I would stuck
to something of this sorted if I have to
finalize between these two so what I
would do you know that's something which
we are talking here you know if we have
a kind of combination where we have to
decide out of these two so both of the
keywords meaning very important if I
would just check from my naked eye a
quick Scan they look very promising they
look very great to me suppose and they
have a equivalent number of searches in
the last you know one year on the
average monthly basis but there is a
difference between the competition okay
now people can be confused what is this
competition so I would just make you
explain in a very simpler way Suppose
there are 100 companies so there are 100
you know ethic institutes or probably
physical institutes who teaches uh
digital marketing because we are doing
online marketing or you know additional
marketing course online so so let's keep
it online institutes like simply learn
and all okay so what they have done is
in the last one year they all have used
these keywords to run their ads you know
to show their advertisement or their
digital ad on a Google space okay when
this data has been given so this is
telling me that out of those 100
advertisers or my 100 competitors
66 or a 66 percent advertisers have used
this ad
okay or have used this keyword to show
their ad okay and out of 100 33 percent
or if it is 100 then 33 advertisers have
used this keyword to show their ad okay
so it brings you know kind of a
comparison to US that probably these two
keywords are very much in demand you
know like equally from the searches
point of view because both have been
searched equally but whenever this has
been searched then there has been a
competition where 66 people or 66
advertisers or 66 percent advertisers
are fighting to show their ad okay and
when this keyword being searched as
equally then only 33 percent or 33
people or 33 advertisers are fighting to
show their ad on Google space okay when
I talk about 100 then that seems to be
okay where my AdWords look like you know
where my ad would show because if I just
go on a Google space you know that only
seven ads are shown when you know when
we go on a Google search engine one two
three and four and then the rest three
would be at the bottom if they are shown
at this moment or not I'm not very sure
so three would be here somewhere so
total seven adds placement on the first
page nobody goes beyond first we know
that 97 of the worldwide audience won't
don't go beyond the first pagination
okay so we have to be on our first page
so if I talk about from the first page
seven positions point of view it would
make more sense so let's imagine there
are only 10 advertisers of digital
marketing course so out of 10 if I take
out 66 66 percent then it means almost
like six to seven advertisers are
fighting or have bidded or probably are
trying to outrank each other to show
their ad on the top or on the first four
versions of Google but when I talk about
this then only three to four advertisers
are fighting or have bidded for this
keyword to show the ad on the first page
so this actually is a very important
data sometimes we just you know Miss it
because it has not been uh I think
explained anywhere else that what
exactly this value is we only go by the
low medium high which is the very first
column I delete nowadays you know I
don't you know go by this because they
both come under the medium but there is
a big difference you know seven out of
10 would have been bidded for and only
three to four would have been bidded for
this keyword so never go by the high
medium or low just go by the index value
because that's a percentage of The
Advertiser who are actually trying to
fight for the same keyword to show their
ad on the top okay this is how we you
know shorten or we get the best keywords
we try to get the best search keyword
with the you know kind of a index value
between 50 to 60 less than that and then
we of course you know go for the bit
value or a bit price which is also on a
very lower side not a very high price
keyword we go with so this is the
criteria you know I actually follow and
that's something which you know you can
see I have also mentioned here you can
see that much uh you know we go for the
high search keyword and then we'll try
to get the low medium competition
keywords which of course less than 60
index value and then I put a price you
know kind of a price of my price you
know which is like if the low bid price
is 10 Rupees then I just make it 13 by
adding 30 to it so if the pricing is 10
so I would add 30 to it that makes my
price 13 and then I check you know uh if
in the first if the Impressions has come
it means my price actually been accepted
but if any of the keyword my price is
not accepted then I would again revise
the price by 20 30 and then would wait
on the secondary report and that's how
you know I keep changing for the first
two three days and keep seeing the
results and once the you know every
keyword gets pick up and I get the you
know it starts getting the stable
results then I uh just allow the
campaign to work uh you know on the
algorithm and uh you know I I see uh
results actually moves in the positive
direction when you give some time to
campaigns to read and to learn uh you
know from the audience Behavior okay so
this is about the keyword planning which
we have just seen
now moving to again a very important
aspect because campaign making is
something which I've already given you
the you know Glimpse in the last class
so I would again give you today but
before that I really you know wanted
today to speak on all these technical
aspects you know which works at the back
end so that's why my focus is more on
this uh presentation parallely I would
keep showing you the uh you know uh the
uh Google ads other demo and everything
okay so now when we move to the next
part next part is very important from
the
um add algorithm point of view so what
happens or what used to happen uh when
when the quality score you know which
I'm just trying to speak now I was not
there uh what used to happen the one who
used to pay the highest bid price used
to get the first position and the second
one used to get the second position and
the third bidder used to get the third
position so I have just brought into
this table suppose a Advertiser has been
at 8 rupee B10 C 15 and D 20 and when
the quality score concept was not there
so they actually been given the very
direct position this one first this one
second this one third and this one
fourth but they have realized or Google
has realized that the one who is paying
the most is not having a very good
quality of the ad uh his uh landing page
or the website it's is not working or
probably the pages which is which are
connected are not very relevant and the
keywords on which the ads been shown is
nowhere near uh you know when the
landing page is open so it it was like a
very negative impact on Google when the
reviews been checked and people or the
users who are clicking on those ads were
not happy so what Google did Google
brought us you know kind of um uh test
score or a check which is called quality
score for every keyword we bid okay and
this is only for the server chats that's
why I said all the keywords we made okay
I'll just show you the result on a
client side so when we submit our ad on
the basis of you know different keyword
we bid and the and the strategy we use
and the landing page we connected the
backend so what the system does is
system starts analyzing and starts
checking everything from top till you
know bottom from the start till the end
and I would just talk about the factors
and what impact it brings is so the
quality score the score which has been
given out of 10 is then been given to
every Advertiser on the basis of the
keyword suppose every Advertiser here is
bidding on the same keyword you know
let's let's
um assume that they all are running the
ad for the digital marketing course so
what would happen they would check and
on the basis of the you know factors
they would give a score out of 10.
suppose the a Advertiser who bid it for
the least had the best of the quality
score because of the reasons we'll just
going to talk about B got 8 out of 10 4
out of 10 and 2 out of ten so the one
who have bidded the most for the very
least quality score probably the reasons
you know would be more clear once we
talk so how this now we're going to
impact the whole position system is that
their Google rank not Google position
okay there is a Google rank kind of uh
kPa can be understood your Matrix which
is a product or a multiplication of what
you bid and how much quality score you
were able to get so 8 into 9 being 72 10
into 8 brings 80 15 into 4 bring 60 and
20 into 2 is 40. okay so the combination
of a good pricing and a good quality
score got B bidder as a first position
okay and the one who got the best
quality score but still paying very less
from the average price in probably is
you know brought the Google position or
add position to Second and then the one
who was spraying very high but the
quality score was below average which is
a Force 5 6 is average price average
score they've got into third position
and the one who was paying so High
probably would not get a position
because this is the maths from the match
point if you have got these numbers if
the quality score would have been below
5 then the ad would not have got any
position rather because Google always
tries to you know show the ads which are
the best uh for the users you know
because Google always pays very
importance to the users behavior and
users you know expectations so and when
I said that I think you were able to
understand more now how the factors you
know which which actually results in
these quality score is
um like relevant score like buy 11 score
means when you type a query or a person
would come here would type a query so he
doesn't know that this is called a
keyword we as additional marketers know
this is called a keyword for them it is
a normal query because they are about to
start a course where they would be
taught about all these things but right
now they are not very aware you know
very much aware of these things so they
are putting a query when they put the
query they want to see the ad or add
extensions or a description relevant to
what they have searched and when they
see all these three things here with the
search uh you know what they made they
would definitely going to click more and
Google only earns when somebody clicks
so it means Google making Revenue only
when somebody is clicking so from that
perspective also Google always tries to
pay you know or rather give more score
and give a better position to the ads
where all the components of the ads are
perfect are relevant and the ones who
starts getting more clicks in the very
first hour or a first day okay so the
important factor which after the click
is the landing page so when somebody
opens this so it has to be very relevant
to this query and do whatever being
shown outside they cannot just show
anything here which is not relevant to
the ad which actually been shown outside
so all these uh you know factors in
combination gives the quality score very
important factor is CTR which you must
have understood when you know we I added
you know explained in the last session
the basic one but if you do not aware of
it so CTR is called click through rate
okay and a click-through rate is a ratio
of clicks to impression
okay it is a ratio of clicks to
impression
I just
a spell check okay so suppose today
uh when we are saying ABCD so let's see
these are this is a or this is B and
this is C and they've got you know
equivalent quality score on the basis of
all what they have done okay their
landing page their uh ad their
description everything is very much
common so Google in the starting of the
day you know when the ad actually
started to show for everyone uh you know
giving them a very good quality score
probably of five okay and when this
quality score of 5 been given to them
then the other factor which actually
adds on you know to that algorithm is
the CTR so CTR is I just told you is the
ratio between click to impression so now
they all have a same quality score but
this got 100 clicks out of the Thousand
Impressions been given today this got 50
clicks out of the Thousand Impressions
given today this got by any mean
probably 200 clicks out of the Thousand
Impressions given today okay every time
this this search is happening here
digital marketing course so these
ads are very much visible equally so all
got thousand Impressions thousand
Impressions thousand Impressions but
this got 100 clicks this got 50 clicks
and this got 200 Clicks in the very
first hour or maybe in the next two
hours okay so this CTR you know when we
are talking about 100 out of 1000 to 10
percent This Is 50 out of thousand it
means this is going to be five percent
and 20 uh sorry 200 out of 1000 means
twenty percent of the CTR so Google was
actually benefited or made the most of
the revenue and you know clicks have
come from here because it is almost like
a double or a four times of this so
because of the high CTR the quality
score of a force you know every every
Advertiser would improve but this one
would be improved from probably from
five to seven and this would you know
probably from 5 to 5.5 and that's
probably from five to six so because of
that quality score has improved and uh
you know because of the high CTR this ad
has got so this position will be changed
and this would you know probably would
get the first page on the second
position and and at the end of a day
this ad has to pay or Advertiser has to
pay lesser because it's quality score
increase we have just seen it is you
know almost like the uh you know
inversely proportional the ones who are
actually paying or the ones who are
having the best of the quality score are
paying the least or has to pay the least
okay so this is all basically you know
can be checked once your ad starts
running so I will just open the clients
account uh where you can just see this
with
in a bit better
understanding you were able to get out
of this
hopefully I am able to show you from
okay I'll just see because I have
multiple
advertisers you know
but I cannot just show for all so let me
just check if I can show you how many of
the older one
just wait it is actually asking you some
verification
it's taking too much time
yeah which is done now
so once this is done
so I'll just take you to one of the
accounts where
my main focus would be to just show you
how the quality score report look like
and then you know you will get a fair
idea about all the factors you have to
be focusing to bring your quality score
high or to take your qualities for high
okay
so I'm just going to open the search ads
because we're talking about a search art
here only and suppose if I just go into
this Campaign which is of course you
know not running right now but I just
want to show you how you check the
report and all suppose this is the
campaign you have run for and you got 75
clicks at uh you know
um average CPC price of 40 PESA and you
have just given this much pricing and I
have made it for many keywords but I
wanna see which keyword had got the best
of the quality score and how the
qualities have been given and all okay
so once you reach to the keyword report
here you know at this level then you see
um uh you know the kpis or metrics here
which gives the quality score out of 10.
okay you can see here very well and
every keyword being given you know if
there are 10 keywords I don't know how
many keywords we waited for we've bidded
50 keywords okay and you know you can
see all the keywords here and every
keyword being given the quality score
out of 10 okay because their CTR which
was the last part which I've explained
you the ratio between the impression two
clicks got the above average so they
give below average average above average
so above average is best actually for
any of the factors so the CTR is above
average the landing pages above average
and their ad is above average means all
are perfect then they got the 10. the
moment anything goes below average or
probably to the average suppose you can
see this is above average for them this
is above average for them but they're
landing page experience from this
keyword point of view is only average
their quality score has come to eight
okay if we go further down uh let's see
anything where two of them yeah so here
the kids ride on is a keyword where CTR
is also not as high or as great you know
to as compared to the other keywords
which we have seen and also the landing
page is not as relevant to the keyword
so there are two factors like CTR and
landing page has come to average as
compared to the Android 11s which is
above average so their whole qualities
for got impacted which actually came
down from 10 to 8 and then 7 for this
particular keyword and last not PC if I
just take you to somewhere where
something is below average has come now
one is above average
one is okay they are getting clicks but
probably the ad is still not very much
relevant to the keyword okay so they are
below average above average has brought
the quality score to 6 out of 10 which
certainly would have you know impacted
on the cost and also to the position
okay so this is something which you
would see
when you come here also you can check
one more thing here suppose you have
bidded for your keyword and your bid
price where you are paying for is
maximum bit price let me just see where
that column is
so otherwise I would just add that
column so that you can learn that part
as well
okay
[Music]
straight okay so this is basically
CPC prize is being given in the average
cost 2.50 is the cost for every click
and we got 249 clicks so we got 623 you
can just check the maths it's always
good to cross check so 249 clicks
multiplied by the CPC price which is
2.50 rupee would give you 6 22.5 which
is the cost you know for the keywords uh
you know we beat it for and the total
clicks we have paid okay and the
maximum beta price suppose you know you
have got uh the maximum bit price of uh
one rupee and you paid 17 PESA 1.66 and
all and then what happens you wanna
secure your position suppose the very
first page bid you're seeing that you're
getting the operation but you're not
getting the first page then here because
this campaign is not running so I'm just
giving you the hypothetical example so
whatever the pricing you would have
given for the particular keyword suppose
we talk about these three keywords right
now or particular one keyword I suppose
so this is something which I'm you know
trying to show on a one rupee cost but
to show on the first page it is saying
that you have to pay 1.5 okay to show on
the uh first four positions here one two
three four it is saying that probably
you have to pay 2.5 and to get the
absolute first position which is going
to be the topmost it would tell you that
you have to probably pay five rupees you
know you're paying one it is asking 1.5
the first four it can be paid for 2.53
or this has to be five so you can always
go and change your you know bid price
for the particular keyword okay so there
are ways to do it suppose if I'll just
go here and I just go to the edit I can
change my maximum CPC bit price for this
particular bid or a keyword like 25
rupee okay because I'm not changing for
all the keywords so I have selected that
particular keyword and I have made the
change to this particular keyword to
five rupee so if you know the average
price was one and I was not getting the
keyword uh from this keyword the
position secured on the first page or
the first absolute position and I want
because this is the most important
keyword for me then I would just come
here and would check the pricing okay
this says five rupees you have to pay
for the top position so I will just go
here edit and would change the bid price
or a maximum CPC bit price of this
particular keyword you can do for all
you know you have to just of course you
know select all of course but if you
would do for all then it you can really
impact your whole budget okay so try to
go for the keywords where you really
feel like it is required and always go
by the quality score it has you know it
has a very good quality score so I
should be paying or I should be ready in
paying uh the maximum price which
actually Google is asking me to pay to
secure my first absolute position and
certainly that would increase the
chances of clicks and certainly if
clicks are there so convergence can be
expected too okay so this is all from
what I've just taught you as of now
now I would just move to the campaign
making though we have done as I told you
last time but I will try to make it
again so that we can quickly see how the
Google ad search ads or the search
Google had created okay so if I just go
to the campaign uh My Demo
account so if you just go to the Google
ads account the dashboard and then I
would come to the campaigns
I will just click Plus
new campaign
and whatever the you know
um
objective is you can always go for
website traffic or without a guidance
because this would have all the settings
inside the same more important part is
what we select next so we select search
campaign because we are making the ad
for the search Network you can always
test for website traffic that would not
make much difference and click continue
I will talk about the conversions and
remarketing in a separate session
altogether so we are not doing the
conversion and remarketing today we are
making a normal search ad with all the
strategies we have just understood and
with uh adding the extensions to the ad
as well today okay website visit and
suppose my website is just open safety
learns
landing page
so that I can make the ad for simple
additional marketing as a demo ad of
course not a mean add
so copying and just putting in here I
have to just put a you know website
domain that's it I don't have to bring
the whole landing page here and then I
can just name it probably November
search ad
and then I would just go and continue
start new
and then I'll just select my bidding
strategy which is going to be clicks
and of course from my Excel I would
learn that okay my bid price which I am
going to be paying uh you know uh is
certainly in the range of something like
probably 50 60 and I have just told you
that I bring my price kind of a thing
into this like I always bring like this
and then
let me just delete all the other columns
which are not required
so this is the sheet which I did explain
to earlier with the index value and all
so my price what is my price like so I
always pay 30 40 extra to the low bit
price so I can you know just get the
formula here like
this Plus
this 30 percent
okay so that is just going to make it 57
so you can just understand 44 plus 13
going to bring 57 and I can just drag it
and now I've got the average suppose
these are the you know keywords which I
have finalized just assuming so these
are the keywords which I have finalized
probably because of x y z factors such
as an index value and all that and I see
that my pricing is varying from 35 to 89
so maximum being 89 so what I would do
keeping that in my head I was going to
give the limit to my bid price and I
don't want to pay anything extra or more
than 90. okay so this is something which
you can do on this particular level
and then you move ahead and you remove
this because you just want to keep your
ad on the Google search and then you go
down you select your countries you
select your location if you want to show
the ad in all the locations then you
certainly can just go and keep the very
first option open which is all countries
and territories if you want to just show
your ad
um
in a particular country like you know
right now if I just go India so the
whole India would see your ad and if you
want to go for a manual locations like
suppose I want to select any of the
states or cities then what I would do I
would just probably take daily so Delhi
would be targeted like this okay or
probably I just want to Target the state
of Texas here so I just would go and
Target the whole state or if I want to
Target any of the provinces of Canada so
I would just go and take the uh
provinces of Ontario Canada and I will
just Target the whole Province and now
if I also want to go for any of the PIN
codes suppose I want to Target to a
certain pin code then I can just go and
Target the PIN codes like this so it is
up to us that we want to go worldwide or
if you want to go for a country specific
if you want to go for us State specific
or if you want to go as a province or a
pin code specific okay otherwise if you
suppose
um a restaurant or if you are a you know
somebody who only delivers into certain
radius then you can just leave all these
options and you can go and advance
search
and then you can go to radius and you
can just bring this whatever you
understand better in India if you
understand kilometers better maybe the
person us would understand miles better
so we just go and take that two
kilometer radius and probably I am the
cake shop in Delhi so I'm just going to
search my location this is my location
and now we're just going to Target
people around two kilometer because I
don't deliver outside two kilometers so
it's all up to us how we're gonna go uh
this is called radius targeting or
geofencing when we go to the locations
we can also learn one thing suppose I
want to show the ad to the
um whole country India I have targeted
at the same time I am not delivering in
um in in in Mumbai okay or probably in
Karnataka you know Bengaluru where the
city is okay or probably I'm not
delivering in any of the northern states
like haryana Himachal Punjab so what I
will do I would just take Punjab suppose
for example and I'm just going to
exclude that okay so what would happen
now my ad would show in all these states
and all the cities of India but just not
in Punjab okay so I can save it that's
how you go about the location language
is you know in which language the users
probably uses the search engine and all
so you can keep it all languages that's
the best and
audience we don't cater here much
because we are doing the search ad which
actually shows the ad on the basis of
keywords and location only so in the
display ad we're going to talk about
this uh one and that would be the next
video I would create so we're going to
learn a lot of things from the audience
segment in the next display ad and then
the more settings comes where you talk
about the ad rotation so add rotation is
uh already default been selected as the
perform best ad uh if because the
nowadays the ad actually been created uh
responsive and dynamic so when we'll
reach to the ad level I'll show you uh
the headline changes for every user the
description sometimes changes for the
user what I mean is if Sachin is
selecting or you know writing this
keyword so probably this headline is
shown to me and after one hour if I'll
come again and put search the same term
so the headline from the same Advertiser
could be different or the description
could be different so that's how these
anime cards works like okay so once you
are done with this okay the start end
date is important and you know the
basics from the previous chapter so I'm
just going a bit faster in here so you
would select the date and
then if you want to schedule this
campaign for a certain period like
suppose you don't want to run on the
weekends so you can just select Monday
to Fridays and you know our timing
whichever suits you suppose just like a
very common time of 8 AM to uh you know
the late nights like 23 45 and you don't
want to run the weekends if you want uh
Saturday Sunday to be you know 24 hours
then you don't have to put any timing so
that goes like 24 hours for Saturday
Sundays and then you click next and you
reach to the next level
where it will just going to ask you for
certain things like keywords you want to
submit and the ad you want to run for
and the ad copy you know you have to
create okay so once you come here it is
the you know work you have done so you
can just copy paste them and you know
bring in there and otherwise these all
keywords are the ones which Google has
suggested you from you know the page
which you have submitted okay so the
landing page is this so I'll try to
change the landing page first so that I
can get more appropriate keywords and
then it would mean to search again on a
scan again for us update keyword
suggestions of course we can always
click on and now the keywords would be
more digital marketing oriented because
this landing page will be scanned by
Google and this would show a certain
results which would of course going to
be digital marketing oriented but why we
don't just uh you know use them because
we don't know uh what is the pricing of
these keywords what is the competition
of this keywords is how much the monthly
search has been so we go by our own
maths we we calculate we do all this
free homework on the Keyword Planner
sheet just like we did today and then we
bring them here by deleting all what
they have actually submitted or
suggested us okay and once this is done
then we ensure that our keyword uh uh
you know in the headlines and everything
been used how that copy is created I'll
just show uh you some you know strategic
part of it ensure that your landing page
is correct and it is opening there you
know otherwise your ad would not be
approved secondly always give a display
path display path is something which is
added after the ad or the landing page
link suppose I'm selling online
foreign
whatever I want to show
or probably I'll just keep it here
okay so that works okay so now it has
computational marketing and then the
part comes where you know you have to be
foreign
extension once the art is created so
headlines and all so the headline is
something which shows
you know you know the basics where I'll
be fast again
under the landing page link this blue
which actually uh you know brings the
most of the engagement or which actually
appeals the user to click it is
something in blue which is you know
going to be the headline so we have to
be focusing very much on bringing the
best of the headlines here so that we
can get the best of the clicks because
you know once the click increases the
CTR increases CTR increases the quality
Square would increase quality Square
would increase your cost you would come
down and your position would rise so you
have to ensure that your headlines your
clicks everything is in you know in a
line whatever we have learned so your
headlines right now has been given these
of course they are not very relevant so
we're going to just bring the headlines
which we feel like are more relevant to
the ad we are showing okay and
I'm just going to get the headlines as a
suggestion being given okay and
we can have more ideas from here by
clicking this so they are not giving any
so we can always have from the keywords
which we have submitted so probably
digital marketing course online
try to get your best keywords here
this is okay
this is nice this can be changed
digital
marketing course
online is not taking so this Marketing
Online probably at this day because
course already submitted and then I can
take few more like social media
marketing I just seen
whatever the length it would accept
I'll take otherwise I'll delete the rest
this is the one and I should ensure that
I have at least 10 headlines or 12
headlines so six been given and headline
section actually you know been given egg
a half blue and then I would see
headlines which are unique so unique you
should have a uh you know online
availability benefits and the offers and
all or call to action so enroll
register
today
for free
demo
then we will talk about
you can see the moment I've added the
headline this the strength has changed
100 plus
tools for free
job
assistant
program
okay so I'm just adding a few random
things I'm just not paying much
attention but yeah of course we would
have seen uh these headlines in any of
the acting companies ads uh include some
popular qos popular keywords could be
your brand name as well so simply
learn
courses
online
of hopefully the spelling is fine and
um
foreign
batch for
professionals
oh
[Music]
um
just a batch for professionals
and that's it you know because I already
added a lot of keywords a lot of
headlines probably they win so I would
just not work on the headlines anymore
uh I'll see you know if deception
doesn't takes it high then I'll just add
one more but right now the description
is also not giving me the full uh tick
like in the headline unique and the
headlines been given so I'll just try to
bring the description so simply an
online to do online that's great that's
great so just try to get something from
Google itself let's see what they have
given so I'll just going to bring this
one
okay so that it is being taken from the
landing page itself so that would make a
difference to
uh the quality score simple digital
marketing courses focus on so we're just
going to put
our courses focus on skills
co22
focus on
else like success
so we're doing this one here so that it
has been picked up so now you can see
this has also been picked up and the
last thing I would do is now going to
bring some headline uh again you know
I'll just check probably
uh digital marketing
notification I'm not sure if this
headline I have somebody earlier or not
but I'm just going to test it out okay
so
you should
foreign
so now it has you know come down to good
and uh that's the best you know right
now we can do of course you can take it
further but yeah that doesn't
um matter if you are just stopping it to
get this one completed you have to just
ensure that all the keywords all of the
headlines are relevant just do not
overdo 10 to 12 are okay okay once this
is done your ad is created you can just
click done and you can click next
and then your budget so we just
discussed about the budget when I was
explaining we'll just take you back so
because you know that your average CPC
price would be around 80 you know
whatever the pricing you have just got
from here if you know the sheet and I
was explaining you so the the bit price
which you have submitted for you know
when I told you is like something which
is in this range uh like 80 90 whatever
it is so you know that bit price would
come down to 90 and you need
um at least 100 clicks today so 90 into
102 MP you are 9000 daily budget so
because you know that you know you would
end up in paying maximum 90 rupees per
click because that's the maximum bit
price you have submitted if that comes
down to 70 80 60 then of course your
clicks would increase but right now
though being very uh you know hypothetic
hypothetically thinking that okay I
would pay 90 rupees per click at Max
because that is what I submitted so to
get 100 clicks I have to pay 90 into 100
which would be 9 000 your you know
delivers it has to be so we would have
come here and you were just going to
change it set a custom budget and you
were going to bring now 9000 Rupees here
okay so on that yeah I have a CPC
whatever it would be you would get the
number of clicks if you have a CPC goes
down from 90 to 45 then of course you
are not going to get only 100 you'd
rather get double amount which is going
to be 200 okay once that is done then
you just click next and your budget goes
uh you know your campaign goes for a
review
and then you can add the extensions from
outside okay so they're just giving you
some of the uh you know kind of uh
suggestions so let's see uh there is one
issue in the ad
let me just check that first
let me just see
you can always fix it
with that foot again you're not going to
give you the option of publishing you
know till you fix it but it is not
clickable or not no
uh what is the problem
I'll just go away from here you know
sometimes those links doesn't work so
let's see what is the issue
foreign
[Music]
okay so because just to do that the
better limit part I have not given the
space so that is something which is not
acceptable by them
just want to put like skills like this
and
now so these all small things you know
they do
take care of so here only because you
have come down so why not you know just
to see the extension here itself because
that would I'm going to save our efforts
by going from outside so when you see
the ad you see some extensions here like
you know when you have created the ad
right now so you have created only till
this limit okay this is the elements you
have put it up right now the landing
page the headline the description but in
this ad by emirators you can see more
links like applied to IMS learn how
industry so one is landing page and
three different uh Pages or a sub page
has also been shown in this same ad how
they are done so they are done through
the extension called site link okay so
you can see here if you go down after
the headline there's an option to have
the site links here okay so you can just
click Plus
here itself you know I'm not submitting
the ad because I wanted just to show you
from here itself and then you can go
down because in your case these would
not be given because mine are already
created yours or not so you would go
down and you would create the new South
new site link from here and you can just
give a name suppose download
brochure
and then you can give a URL of that
download brochure page right now I'm
using this URL and I'm just going to be
adding my own made page
like this like this has to be the
landing page which is workable for the
downloading brochure of course so this
would be added and then I can just go
and probably add
um
testy nails
and reviews
okay so somebody wants to leave the uh
you know testimons and reviews of when
they see the ad so you can see that on
the desktop how that would look like so
they would have an ad and then they
would have these four links involved
which you have just seen the Google when
I show you so final URL of reviews can
be given which should directly take them
to the page where the reviews being
given and site 2 could be anything you
know which can just see
um industry ready modules or the fee
structure you know the fee structure is
something which people always wants to
just know
from the uh very first glimpse of the
art itself so I can just maybe
take them to the page where V is
actually been you know talked about and
the last could be uh maybe tools
provided
the tools and
certificates
you would get so that can also be one of
the links which people would very much
interested in you know clicking and
checking okay so you would see the the
ad in certain shape you would have a
normal headline uh the description which
you have put it up and then four links
where people can directly reach okay and
then you know this had to be saved here
and you can always see the preview which
I've already shown you but yeah this is
how that would look like so you add
your ad and your four
extra links which actually been added
okay so this is one which you can apply
now
and now your ad has the extensions in
addition to that you might have seen
somewhere that you know your ad as the
number as well sometimes you see the
number being given here because right
now it is not showing any of the ads
with the number but the you know uh
generally have when advertisers have
nowadays the numbers in addition to the
headline and everything okay so you can
add that as well by just going up and
you can see there is an option of calls
okay okay let me you can add from here
uh certainly I can show you wow you know
you can just go down and add the number
by clicking your
country and you know giving your number
here it will just be cross checked by
some verification and all so that is
done you can save it so you can see what
actually I was showing you you know I
would just show you
um from outside also that if by any of
the uh you know
um that is done that we have corrected
so you don't have to be you know
uh worried about so if I just click done
so that should not be there if it is
still there I have to check now which
spacing it is actually talking about
um
actually I have unacceptable spacing
contains comma and I think I have just
corrected it but it is not taking maybe
I have to just
um
delete the whole description properly
that would something which
and I would save our time
so you're not adding the description
though
let's click done so this is actually you
know kind of a bug because that is
something which has been deleted rather
in front of you so this is not
um
taking but I would just click next and
probably this would now be not the error
in which we would see
so you go for a review so what I was
saying I did shown you from outside the
you know the the campaign was created
from the ad itself how the site link is
connected and how the uh call been added
for now the publish campaign you can see
because that ad error actually been
rectified so if by mistake you know you
just forgotten that you have to add the
call number or extension you know which
we just added so but you don't have to
be worried because once you back to the
dashboard you know where you would see
all your campaigns certainly you would
see your this campaign as well in which
you had just created then you can just
go inside the
um add group and then
you can see there is ADD and assets
let me just click that
so there is an ad which you just created
and there's an assets
you know where you could see the
extensions and like you know you just
have added today now we just started
this site link and this number so if I
want to add again or if I would have
forgotten then what I can do I can just
go and take from here suppose if that
call extension was not added there you
know when I just added you would come
here in the assets you would click that
plus button
and then you would just go to the call
and you would see the same kind of a
preview which you have seen inside the
ad when we were creating okay nothing
different it's just like the you know
where you do it you know either you do
when the ad was created or otherwise you
can just go uh let the campaign be
created published and you can come from
outside you can click the add an assets
you can go to plus and you can create
any of these extensions I will talk
about more in the coming you know
tutorials and demos uh and the sessions
but today you know we'll wind up here I
just uh you know wanted to give you the
thorough learning on the Google search
ad with the extensions and also the main
uh agenda for today was to make you
understand how these you know terms
works like and how the keywords can be
researched how you can bring your own
pricing to the keywords how can you save
the cost and of course to understand how
the quality score works like you can
have a lot of videos on a YouTube where
you can find the quality score of Google
ads working though I try to you know
bring everything under this session but
still if you want to go for a deep
learning you can always search more and
research more
so thank you from my side please leave
your comments with your feedbacks if you
have any questions you can always leave
in the comments and if you are watching
the very first video on our Channel I
request you to if you have not
subscribed it please subscribe it and do
not forget to press the Bell icon so
that you're not uh you know leaving any
of the important notifications okay so
we have a lot of content uh just not on
digital marketing on every topic you
know you would name it and you would
find it it's it's a great platform to
learn and to you know improve your
skills uh just just be a part of this
community and as I said we always try to
improve and you know your comments
always motivates us so leave your
valuable comments and I will see you in
the next tutorial very soon that would
be completely on Google ads Display
Network and where I would talk about the
audiences and you know a lot of
targeting methods which are differ from
the search ad and later I would you know
talk about the advanced
you know session of remarketing and
conversion and all so a lot of things
are coming if you're not subscribed
please subscribe so you don't miss
anything thank you so much uh this had
such Incycle again signing off from
Simply learn have a great day ahead God
bless take care of yourself and your
families bye
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here